Il y a trois ans, j'ai voyagé en République centrafricaine
pour faire un rapport de la guerre en cours.
J'avais entendu des avertissements de massacres
dans les jungles et les déserts du pays,
mais personne ne pouvait localiser ces massacres,
ni me dire qui a été tué, ou quand.
J'ai foncé dans cette guerre
avec peu d'informations.
J'ai assisté à des scènes tragiques et irréelles,
et c'est seulement à la fin que j'ai réalisé
que j'avais assisté à la lente préparation d'un nettoyage ethnique.
La République centrafricaine est un pays d'environ cinq millions de personnes,
de la taille du Texas,
au centre de l'Afrique.
Elle connaît une violence chronique
depuis la fin de la colonisation française, en 1960.
La guerre que j'ai rapportée
était entre le gouvernement musulman minoritaire,
appelé la Seleka,
et les milices citoyennes,
à majorité chrétienne,
appelées l'anti-balaka.
Le premier signe de la purification imminente
était la rupture de confiance au sein des communautés.
Trois jours après mon arrivée au pays,
j'ai vu que la petite ville de Gaga allait être abandonnée.
Une bataille allait éclater.
Et afin de sauver leurs vies,
beaucoup de gens travaillaient en tant qu'espions pour le gouvernement,
identifiant les amis et les voisins
à tuer.
Les cités et les villes,
n'importe quel endroit habité, était devenu dangereux.
Alors les gens ont fui dans la jungle.
Je me sentais bizarrement isolé
comme les porcs et le bétail qui se déplaçaient dans les maisons vides.
Dans une zone de guerre,
vous savez que vous êtes près de la mort quand les gens sont partis.
La guerre se déplaçait à travers la jungle jusqu'à Gaga,
et j'étais entouré par un tonnerre de bombes.
Les forces ont foncé dans la jungle pour attaquer une ville abritant une milice.
J'ai conduit une moto pendant des heures,
traversant des jungles et des grandes herbes.
Mais je me suis retrouvé à la ville
après que le gouvernement l'a brûlée
et que ses habitants avaient fui.
Pour voir si je pouvais parler à quelqu'un,
j'ai annoncé que j'étais un ami, que je ne leur ferais pas de mal.
Une femme dans une chemise rouge a couru hors de la forêt.
Les autres ont prudemment émergé des arbres
et ont demandé : (en français) « Est-ce que les gens savent ? »
« Est-ce que les gens savent ? »
La question m'a surpris.
Leurs enfants avaient faim et étaient malades,
mais ils n'ont pas demandé de la nourriture ni des médicaments.
Ils m'ont demandé :
« Est-ce que les gens savent ce qu'il nous arrive ? »
Je me sentais impuissant lorsque j'ai noté leurs questions.
Et je suis devenu déterminé
à ce que ce moment dans leur vie
ne soit pas oublié.
En assistant à leur crise,
j'ai ressenti une petite communion avec ces gens.
Loin de là, cette guerre passait au second plan aux informations.
En tant que témoin,
je ressentais la guerre comme une histoire qui se déroule.
Le gouvernement a nié avoir commis des violences,
mais je continuais à conduire à travers les villes
où les gens ont décrit les massacres du gouvernement,
la veille ou une semaine auparavant.
Je me sentais submergé
et j'ai essayé de me calmer.
Au moment où je rapportais ces massacres,
j'ai acheté et mangé
des petits bonbons,
cherchant le confort familier de leur goût.
Les Centrafricains ont mangé ces bonbons
pour soulager leur faim,
laissant une traînée de milliers d'emballages en plastique.
Sur les quelques stations de radio encore actives dans le pays,
j'ai surtout entendu de la musique pop.
Quand la guerre s'intensifiait,
nous avons reçu moins d'informations à propos des massacres.
Il est devenu plus facile de ressentir un sentiment de normalité.
J'ai été témoin de l'effet de cette information manquante.
Deux semaines plus tard, j'ai lentement et anxieusement
roulé vers un quartier général isolé de la milice,
une ville appelée PK100.
Ici, les combattants chrétiens m'ont dit
que tous les musulmans étaient des étrangers,
méchants et alliés avec le gouvernement.
Ils ont comparé les musulmans aux animaux.
Sans observateurs neutres ou médias
pour contrer ce récit absurde,
il est devenu le seul récit dans ces camps.
Les milices ont commencé à traquer les musulmans,
et ont vidé la capitale, Bangui,
de près de 140 000 musulmans
en quelques mois.
La plupart des meurtres n'ont pas été signalés par des témoins.
Je vous parle de mes reportages en République centrafricaine,
mais je me demande toujours pourquoi je suis allé là-bas.
Pourquoi me mettre en danger ?
Je fais ce travail
parce que je sens que les gens ignorés dans toutes nos communautés
nous disent quelque chose d'important
à propos de qui nous sommes.
Lorsque l'information est manque,
les gens ont le pouvoir de manipuler la réalité.
Sans témoins,
nous allons croire que ces milliers des personnes massacrées sont toujours en vie,
que ces centaines de maisons brûlées sont toujours en place.
Une zone de guerre peut passer
pour un endroit plutôt paisible
lorsque personne ne la regarde.
Et un témoin peut devenir précieux,
et son regard plus que nécessaire,
quand la violence passe silencieusement,
sans être vue ni entendue.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)